it's this overwhelming stepping back
into the real world it is so
overwhelming I went from the same Mouse
all day every day to now people lots of
people you had a great moment sitting up
on the stage with Julie and you saw your
family in the audience what was that
moment like for you that moment I can't
even think about it is it means
everything
this whole journey I've never been away
from home I never have been on a plane
I've never been to California and to be
away from them for 99 days has been so
so difficult they're my best friends
they're my people they're they're my
life and I've missed them so much and I
just love him so much so seeing them
just it just overcame me oh gosh well I
love them and then to be named America's
favorite houseguest
have you even processed that yet no it's
honestly it still hasn't even sunk in
I've gone through this little season
like oh I'm just Nicole I really hope in
future seasons it's not who's another
girl no she was kind of weird she was
kind of quirky like that was my biggest
fear so I don't see myself as noteworthy
I just see myself as Nicole from Long
Island so to find that out and there's
so much love and so much respecting so
much like you're my favorite I my I
can't I don't know yeah whenever you get
your phone back on the internet you're
gonna see that you are everybody's like
my winner my winner my winner wow that
means so so much I was my winner too and
I really really wanted to win but I'm a
firm believer that things work out the
way they should the way they should
rather and to be honest
America's favorite America that means so
much more to me than you will ever know
it means so much more than even winning
but Mickey won yes how are we feeling
about that to be honest I mean I played
the game with the guy for 99 days he is
good he is good at what it counts he's
got a mental comp that dude pretended he
couldn't do a puzzle but he can do a
puzzle he is a competition beast and
ultimately regardless of anything else
this is a game and whether he live
manipulator whatever it's a game and he
owned he's a beast but he did not get
your vote who gave your vote to Holly
why did Holly get your vote over Mickey
so living in the house within that last
week was very like informative I
actually got to sit down with Holly
this whole game in the dr like i
dismissed her a she's with she's with
making she's on Mickey's coattails
whatever okay and I didn't give her
enough credit so sitting with her on
that backyard and hearing her talk about
her strategy and how she's gonna lay low
and she's actually very smart and she
was whipping out when she needed it and
she did she was right behind Mickey in
part one of that HOH right behind him
she blew me out of the water with a
mental comps and I'm supposed to be the
smart one
so in talking with her out outside in
the yard I was like oh my gosh like she
has my strategy of laying low and
pulling it out the winds when you need
them and obviously I respect my games so
it made me respect her and her game all
the more and just in having that
conversation I was like wow you really
you haven't been given enough credit I
don't know by anyone but especially not
by me and I wanted to show that to her
that I could give her credit before we
got to learn who the winner was some
harsh truths had to be faced sitting up
on that stage watching Jackson and Jack
and Christie face what they did this
season what was it like to watch that
process that it's very it's very scary
you know I've lived with these people
and I know there was a whole incident
when they locked me out of the room and
that was my incident I don't know what
was said but I was able to move forward
and forgive and just proceed and I
didn't know it was like still a thing I
didn't I don't know how bad it is I
haven't seen it and I I always say these
people are my friends they're my friends
so when I hear these things I worry
about the people they've hurt the people
they've said things about obviously and
I do also worry about them because I
know social media can attack and I think
it was it was very frightening to hear
those things on stage because I don't
you know I only know from Nicole's game
like Nicole had fun Nicole is nice to
everyone and to hear that it's like oh
no like what went wrong and when and
it's very scary very scary I think
everyone will get to go home watch it
maybe learn some things we'll see you
and cliff really bonded in this game you
were carrying his hat out tonight have
you guys gotten to reconnect yet tonight
we spoke a little bit on stage just like
a hug and I like that you didn't I
warned you to win but I haven't been
able to speak to him yet I love Clint
he's my best buddy can we talk some jury
news that happened Nick and Kat are
together now ish together ish reacts
learning that no surprise I said it we
were all looking at the memory wall the
other day thinking about the dynamics of
the jury and halima curling about Nick
and Kat and I was like oh and they were
like no Kat hated him and I was like and
they're like no I'm telling you I was
like alright I guess we'll see well we
see now I called him I am not involved
in nor do I want to be there you go I
want to take it back to a moment in your
game that might have changed everything
should you have guys have kept Tommy
instead of Holly okay I would a large
part of me argues yes Nicole for my game
for Nicole get Nicole's game - Cole
you're an idiot if I woulda went to
Final Four with cliff Tommy and Mickey
there's a very good chance at final
three that all three of them would bring
me and I could be in those final two
chairs but at that point in the game it
wasn't about just getting me there it
was about also getting clipped there I
wanted me and cliff both methan Ally and
we thought our best option was keeping
Holly not so much because of the
Alliance but because we really thought
we could beat Holly we thought if mental
comps were coming we could blow Holly
out of the water but Tommy maybe not so
much but like I said Holly strategy
worked she made us think she's a lot
dumber than she is and she is a smart
cookie all right I know you just stepped
out of this house but you didn't win so
do you want to go back in there and win
this thing absolutely you know I'm in
there and I laugh and then I cry and
then I'm fine and then I cry and then
I'll and then I complain about my family
and then I cry but you know what truth
be told I've loved the experience I'm so
transformed on the other end of it and I
love it I would go in right now and I'm
shocked to even say it but I would let's
do it I'm ready as a BB fan it was
everything you wanted it to be and then
some it was far far more difficult than
I ever expected it to be it's one it's
the most difficult thing I've ever done
in my life but as a fan I'm so proud of
myself a while I was able to do and I'm
telling you if you're a fan and you feel
it in your gut this is what you're meant
to do audition do it I'm telling you I
felt it in my gut in here I am
you
[Applause]
[Music]